he's Charles Davis here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Charles I'm doing
very well rich doing very well I don't
think I even got a dowry at of it you
didn't get anything right worth where
were you guys registered you know it was
fun I think we were just starting to get
that part taken care of I mean the irony
of the whole situations we had spent a
little time together
yeah me J kevin burkhart our producer
director the whole thing we actually
went to spend a day with him in
Nashville and then we were just getting
started on the process of okay Cheers
we're going to do a practice game when I
do for rehearsal here is all that and
obviously he got the call and that point
became moot is Jesse Jackson said on
Saturday night Lo and I look I know your
kids are just like you locked in on the
pop-culture front and so more
importantly do you get to meet Kristen
Catalan when you were hanging out no and
my and my daughter is bitter I knew okay
yeah you do it I sensed it you know you
understand daughter is a daughter's
little hostile right now because she
said what yeah I wanted to meet you know
because it's way bigger than than just
me and Jay getting to work together it
wasn't really more about all about
Kristen so you never you never even
practiced in the booth with Jay it was
just a get to know you that we would get
get to know you and we were getting
ready we were going to do a rehearsal
probably nine probably it was scheduled
for about a week later a little bit less
than a week and hip obviously he got the
calm was able to move on
so we were going to get together the Fox
seminar and start the rehearsal process
between Matt and a couple of other games
coming up and then a preseason game was
already scheduled for us for this coming
weekend with the Chicago Bears at
Tennessee Titans but I just tell you is
funny rich and I'll tell you real quick
sure I had already scheduled going to
visit the Dolphins training camp because
you know I live in Florida so I get
around to the different places where I
can and I'd already scheduled a week in
advance so I was driving down Thursday
late afternoon because I wanted to be in
position because they practice early
Friday morning and the first report came
about Ryan Tannehill unfortunate knee
injury okay well we knew he had injury
last year hope he's okay then later on
hey the report was this looks serious
and that was my first thought was okay
at
serious is there good is it possibly
sound I think Adams going Adam GaSe is
going to call Jay cutlet and then the
next day I went to practice actually
spent time after practice never brought
it up because I didn't feel it was my
place to bring it up but just listening
to the conversation and chatter the
whole thing I walked out of there
convinced that Jay would at least get a
call and whether he would take it or not
I did not know went on from there to
Nashville to the Titans training camp
came home on Sunday rich driving home
and the radio flashed a breaking news
Jay Cutler saw him with the dolphin so
you know you knew it hadn't happened
fast it was going to happen but more
power to him you offered me ten million
dollars yeah and I think something
bigger than that I think a chance to
write a different chapter to his legacy
as a football player because Jays been
11 year starting quarterback they've
been he's been to the playoffs one time
in his career he's got a chance to go
back again and maybe change some
perception about how he's viewed and I
wish him all the best well um how do you
think he's going to do Charles I mean
how do you think this is going to work
here in the Patriots division well the
funny part was who's our guy they're
Jarvis Landry did he guarantee a sweep
of New England in the offseason yeah so
they already put it out there but that
was before some things started happening
to that football team the same day that
Ryan Tannehill went down rich to plays
later in practice and it almost went
unnoticed Ted Larson starting offensive
guard went down had a better bicep he's
out
Raekwon McMillan the linebacker they
draft Ohio State gone for the season of
the ACL they just signed raven i luga to
try and replace him when you start to
have those dings and bangs along the way
you don't have the same team you had I
think Jay will be okay there and it's
not just because he knows Adams offense
it's because he trusts him I mean
looking back in the year that he had and
well I know this ad this can sound trite
to people but at the end of that season
and you and I both know Jay Cutler's
have a lot of dance partner head coaches
offensive coordinators right at the end
of that season you remember what he did
sent his he sent a tailor to Adam GaSe
to the office
the Sudirman budem is an appreciation
for the year that they had so it's much
deeper than just simply he knows the
playbook in this net there's a trust
factor that goes along big-time and I
thought that the move that Jay and my
Tannenbaum and Chris Greer their general
manager dolphin's made was Keynes Ian
meaning they could have done it
conventionally and hoped to be eight
Nate maybe push with Matt Moore but
instead they took a little bit of a leap
in order to try and be great and I
applaud them for giving it a shot
Charles Davis of Fox Sports NFL Network
joining me here on the show you're going
to see the Bears this Sunday what what
do you and you were there with us in
Philadelphia when true Biscay got
drafted and the whole place went nuts
and everybody started scratching their
heads whether this was the right move
and now I show saying if Cutler last
year to John Fox didn't earn anything
until he earned it then why does Mike
Glennon have this gig over troupis yeah
Charles yeah yeah that's a great
question rich I know they signed Mike in
the offseason thinking he would be the
guy I don't know that everyone in
Chicago had sat down and come to a
consensus about drafted Mitchel true
biscuit
I think Ryan pace was conviction about
him and decided that's where they wanted
to go I think that if they want to be a
team that can can get back into the mix
in the NFC North you've got to have a
guy that you count on as a trigger guy
and them drafting for Biscay tells you
that they didn't have that kind of
conviction about Mike Glennon or they
think he's definitely an upgrade so they
made the move and if you make that kind
of move rich I'm of the opinion that
there's there's if we know it's not not
if but when
I would go ahead and get your Biscay in
the saddle as fast as I could
well I mean cuz just big the way no I
don't see any reason to wait well it's
the way he looks to Charles it's it's
not as if he doesn't know where he's
going with the football and it's not as
if he can't get out of trouble with his
legs it does appear that that that that
for somebody who might have to learn on
the job he doesn't look lost right now
now I understand he's
going against threes with a lot of man
coverage and the Atlanta Falcons are
first up and they have a particular bit
of nastiness on that defensive side of
the ball by the way Dan Quinn joining us
on the show tomorrow
but here but you got you got to wonder
why why not for a team that I don't
believe has any playoff hopes with Mike
Glennon here brain 13 last year if I
draft him I'm finding a way to get him
ready to play otherwise to me I'm just
wasting games
remember when bortles first came in with
Jacksonville and Dave Coggeshall and
that crew told us that he was going to
pretty much redshirt that year and what
was it three four games in yeah I was
like well you counted wasted three or
four games didn't you me Milo coned
played him that's the way I look at
things I know that they have their
reasons and all but here's the other
part of it too could there have been a
worse juxtaposition in game one rich the
Mike Glennon Wright who had to fight
this all off since true Biscay got
drafted you know he's the guy he goes
out during the first series he throws a
pick six and then as soon as good trip
if he gets on the field he runs the
two-minute drill there stick it in the
end zone played with a touchdown pass
and not only that Travis Keefe in it by
him doing that how fast did it go from
God we don't know he can't even take a
snap because you remember his first day
at practice because I know you know got
the reported you know three from this
travesty came to take a snap right now
and that's all gone and now everybody's
firmly on the Travis key travesty train
and Chicago's been trying to get it
right a quarterback for a long long time
yeah I think that you know I'm going to
see them this weekend I can't wait to
ask John Fox Andrew where we going with
this what's going to happen because I do
see them in the opener as well I would
not be surprised if your Biscay takes
the first snap when they play Atlanta
part of a doubleheader on Fox Chicago at
Tennessee at 1:00 and in Cincinnati of
Washington at 4:30 Eastern Time Charles
Davis here on the show so we all know
again Fox has the NFC package who do you
think wins the NFC who do you think reps
the NFC in Minnesota this year when it's
all said and done well I'm not counting
Atlanta out by any stretch everybody's
going on the hangover thing the whole
teal CQ was in Seattle then he left he
was there when they had to discipline
against New England I think that behind
closed door
it wouldn't surprise me at all DQ stood
up in front of that team it said guys I
might not have handled things well down
the stretch and I plan to get better ba
bla bla ie a team believes in him and
likes him I'm not saying he gets a free
pass I also think that they you know a
guy like DQ will stand up in front of
his team and expose himself a little bit
and I think that that little bit of
vulnerability goes a long way with some
of those guys rather than hold the
position that they may not believe in
Pete Carroll did a fantastic job in
trying to keep Seattle rallied after the
interception against the New England but
the guys didn't believe it
remember he never said it was a bad call
yo he said the outcome was bad and I
think a lot of those guys thought he was
parsing words the only reason I say that
is why was Richard Sherman still yell
Matt Darrell Bevell two seasons later
which last year during a regular season
game to run the football it's stuck in
their craw a long time I think I think
Atlanta has a better chance of releasing
those feelings and so I'm not counting
them out I firmly expect them to see
Green Bay again down the stretch I
really think those are the teams Charles
love chatting with you good luck over
the weekend and then throughout the
season let's check back in with each
other
okay look forward to it and thanks for
the support is always come on one - hey
before I let you go talk to you tell me
how is Tennessee gonna look this year
what do you think of Tennessee I think
that they can be a little bit of a
surprise but someone there told me the
other day the big the biggest thing
there is to keep the confidence of the
fans because we are on a good track but
maybe we're not a championship team yet
we'll see all right they're 25th in the
top 25 poll number one being Alabama
that just came out by the way preseason
well we'll see we'll see you in
Arlington for Michigan Florida big gap
oh my gosh that's a great opener
I know great open I know but Florida
suspended seven players for it yes yes
it's night and one of them one of them
might be on might be on his opportunity
7 as well so take care yourself Charles
we'll check down a little rich you got
you got it sir Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio sir
across the country and audience if you
like some of that get some more of that
on the rich eyes and show lap follow all
the information you see right here on
the Rich Eisen show